CBS News senior national security
contributor Michael morale served as CIA
deputy director and acting director he
joins us from Washington Michael good
morning morning are we played that clip
of my interview with the crown prince
because of that last thing he said if
Iran develops a nuclear weapon would
Saudi Arabia follow suit and he
suggested yes is that one of the deep
concerns about President Trump
withdrawing from this deal yes so if the
Iranians go back to developing a nuclear
weapon and do so there is no doubt in my
mind that the Saudis would follow suit
and it would be likely that the
Egyptians and the Emiratis would think
about doing so as well so that is one of
the concerns north and let me ask you
about this we have everyone from the US
intelligence community to the IAEA all
international and even some of the
president's top adviser said Iran was in
compliance there they had abandoned much
of their nuclear weapons program how
reckless is this decision and do you
expect that Iran will move forward to be
restart their program nor the Iranians
have a decision to make the ball is in
their court if they stick with the deal
then they can continue to get economic
benefits from the rest of the world and
if they don't stick with the deal if
they go back to their program then the
rest of the world will likely reimpose
sanctions as well one of the things
that's important to remember here is
that when the u.s. first put sanctions
on Iran years ago it wasn't enough to
bring the Iranians to the negotiating
table
it took the rest of the world to do so
the Europeans the Chinese the Japanese
the South Koreans everyone so if it's
just the u.s. I'm concerned there won't
be enough pressure there and the
Iranians the Iranians will decide
whether or not that happens
McDuffie Europeans also have a decision
to make because the sanctions here that
used to be in place penalized European
companies that did business with Iran so
the Europeans have a card to play here
too so if if we put those sanctions back
in place and say European companies
can't do business with US companies if
they're doing business with Iran
the Europeans are in a position to
impose blocking legislation in other
words to impose penalties on US firms
operating there so one of the risks of
going down the road the president has
gone down is it would actually create a
trade crisis between Europe and United
States so Mike we keep hearing about the
negative ramifications of this deal do
you see any upside of the the
president's decision so the people who
are saying there's there's no plan B
here
gaile are wrong there is clearly a plan
B which is put enough pressure on the
Iranians and we're going to need the
Europeans to do that so so so Bolton is
going to have a conversation with them
put enough pressure on them to bring
them back to the negotiating table and
get a better deal that's the plan the
the issue is that it is very very risky
to see whether that are or not that's
going to happen like you've been in the
room when these kinds of difficult
things are worked through give us a
sense of how complicated it is for an
administration to both manage the tricky
situation that now is going to arise in
Iran and also manage the upcoming talks
with North Korea at the same time so I
think it's certainly possible to do both
one of the one of the issues John that
you hear is that this will be a negative
for North Korea right the North Koreans
aren't going to make a deal with the
United States if they are afraid the
next administration is going to abandon
it I actually agree with the national
security adviser that if this puts more
pressure on North Korea to come up with
a better deal than they would have come
up with otherwise so I agree with him on
that all right Michael Morell thanks so
much
you're welcome